ستعود يوما بهذه الثقه يحدثك الاوكرانيون
عن القرم لا تخرج شبه الجزيره التي ضمتها
موسكو عام 2014 عن دائرت هجمات كييف
ضمن بنك الاهداف القريبه قياده اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي في سيفاستوبول
القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه ان ضربه الجمعه
الماضيه صاروخيه هناك افضت الى مقتل 34
شخصا بينهم قائد الاسطول الروسي فيكتور
سكولوف
واشارت الى ان 105 اخرين اصيبوا في الهجوم
هو واحد من هجمات يقرا فيها خبراء عسكريون
صعوبات تواجهها انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه في صد الضربات المنتظمه على شبه
جزيره القرم مع ذلك تعلن موسكو بين الفينه
والاخرى عن افشال هجمات بالمسيرات فوق
القرم وعلى قطع بحريه روسيه في البحر
الاسود
واتبعت ذلك اخيرا ببيان عن اسقاط طائرات
مسيره عده اطلقتها اوكرانيا لمهاجمه منطقه
تايك
الروسيتين لكن لمن الغلبه حقا في الميدان
الثابت انا الاشتباكات لا تنقطع على محاور
القتال المختلفه ولا تنقطع كذلك الهجمات
التي تدار من بعيد في الجنوب الاوكراني
يهاجم الروس جوا بلده في منطقه خرسون كما
يهاجمون بانتظام منطقه اوديسا فتلحق
مسيراتهم وصواريخهم فرط الصوتيه بالغ
الضرر بالبنيه التحتيه لموانئ تصدير
الحبوب الى الشرق يهاجم الاوكرانيون
مستودعات عسكريه في مدينه كراسنودون
بمنطقه لوغانس في اقليم دامباس كما
يتحدثون عن تحقيق المزيد من الاختراقات
على محور بخموت في دنيا
وكذا جنوبا في مقاطعه ذابروجيا في
محاولتها التقدم نحو مدينتي ميلوتوبل
وبرديانسك
ومع ان موسكو في تقدم الجيش الاوكراني على
اي من محاور القتال تجاهد كييف لتثبيت
الانطباع بمضي هجومها المضاد بثبات نحو
انجاز اهدافه مما يمكن ان يعين على ذلك
وفاء الحلفاء الغربيين بتعهدات الدعم
والتسليح
نال الرئيس الاوكراني ما وعد به في ثانيه
زيارته الى واشنطن منذ بدء الحرب في بلده
لم يعد زيلينسكي بحزمه جديده من المساعدات
العسكريه فحسب وانما ايضا بتفعيل الوعد
الامريكي بتسليم الجيش الاوكراني 31 دبابه
من طراز ابرامز ام واحد مزوده بذخائر
مضاده للدروع
اكدت بالفعل تسلمها اول دفعه من تلك
الدبابات وجرى اعدادها لتعزيز الالويه
الاوكرانيه
تنقل صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه عن
مسؤولين في واشنطن قولهم ان دبابات ابرامز
امريكيه صنع وصلت الى اوكرانيا في الوقت
المناسب